how are you doing after that oh I'm
doing good I not everyday do you hold a
giant snake in your hands and not be
terrified Val Chmerkovskiy took a walk
on the wild side Saturday night
attending the Steve Irwin gala in
Beverly Hills Val opened up to et about
his Dancing with the Stars partner
normani Corday and revealed what they
have planned for the semi-finals I had a
wonderful season with norm on accord a
very proud of her I'm proud of how far
she's come
I think she's made a really strong case
to be the winner this season but we will
see no Monty is going to be talking
about it how she is from New Orleans and
how Katrina moved her out of New Orleans
and and how much that experience has
played in motivating her to you know to
do well so that she could make a family
proud because of all the sacrifices that
I made for my brother with no money yeah
I mean I'm I'm certainly rooting for
them now okay it's time I think you know
reasons good as well cement vials and
you know Rashad and Emma are very good
no money is exceptional though overall
normanni has like a full package with
fan base and dancing and the personality
and everything that that Dancing with
the Stars champions that are supposed to
look like
you
you